[Music]
the Resident Evil franchise has a
sprawling timeline that interweaves its
complex narrative across eight Mainline
games a handful of spin-offs and
countless DLC expansions
but how does it all tie together well
largely it's pretty linear what's not so
straightforward is that the
ever-evolving timeline takes in
everything from corporate conspiracies
and human cloning to the American
president's daughter and whatever the
hell this thing is
from the convoluted creation of the
Umbrella Corporation through to the
gothic horror of Resident Evil Village
via the crowd-pleasing boulder punching
antics of one Chris Redfield hey my
name's Adam and this is the complete
timeline of Resident Evil
foreign
[Music]
chronologically speaking our story kicks
off with a good chunk of backstory for
Resident Evil Village the main story of
which book ends this timeline right at
the very end in the early 20th century
the main villain of Rezi Village mother
Miranda is living out her life
peacefully in Eastern Europe with her
daughter Eva until the Spanish Flu
pandemic whips through her community in
1919 killing all and Sundry Eva's death
sends Miranda into a downward spiral and
she Ventures off into a cave Network
Beneath The Village to seek out death
ironically instead of finding a quick
death she discovers a form of mold known
as the mega my seat a genome which gifts
her with regenerative abilities armed
with this newfound power and knowledge
Miranda seeks to use it to bring her
daughter back to life Miranda continues
to experiment with the mega my seat
genome over the next couple of decades
and she eventually creates the kadu
parasite which will crop up again when
we come back round to resonate evil
Village anyway the year is now 1951 and
a young British medical student has
stumbled onto Miranda's research after
getting lost on a hiking Expedition this
young whippersnapper turns out to be one
Oswald e Spencer who will prove to be
very important on this timeline but I'm
getting ahead of myself Spencer is
impressed with Miranda's work and it
inspires him to undertake his own
devious Research into instigating the
next level of human evolution more on
that very shortly he even nabs a local
symbol representing the Sigil of the
four houses of the area as inspiration
for his iconic logo a logo that also
looks a lot like an umbrella speaking of
umbrella let's chart the origins of that
despicable company
foreign
1962 Spencer commissioned architect
George Trevor to design and build a
certain mansion and research laboratory
in the arclay mountains Trevor finally
finishes his mad Masterpiece in 1967 and
it's a labyrinth in structure full of
locked doors that make no logical sense
and in order to hide the mansion's
terrible Secrets forever Spencer being
the awful bastard that he is invites the
Trevor family to stay and well they
never leave Across The Swinging 60s he
joins forces with University pal James
Marcus an eccentric millionaire Edward
Ashford on an expedition to locate a
legendary African flower known as The
Stairway to the sun this flower is said
to contain powerful properties and this
is confirmed when the trio extract the
progenitor virus from it this virus has
the ability to genetically alter
organisms and they immediately transport
it back to the USA our evil Trio then
established the Umbrella Corporation as
a legitimate Pharmaceuticals company as
I cover for their totally illegitimate
viral research and their ultimate goal
of creating a race of superhumans or at
least that's Spencer's ultimate goal
Astrid becomes increasingly frustrated
with the other two and he makes for
Antarctica to set up his own research
Labs which would later hold the code
Veronica project Ashford never sees the
code Veronica project come to fruition
though as in July 1968 he's injected
with a progenitor virus himself on the
orders of all-around Bad Eggs Spencer
and he swiftly dies
he was succeeded by his son Alexander
who takes control of the Antarctica
umbrella lab in an effort to keep his
father's work going albeit with more of
a focus on cloning back in the USA
Spencer and Marcus take control of
umbrella facilities in the arclay
mountains just outside of Raccoon City
Spencer continues his research into the
progenitor virus in the lab under the
newly constructed Mansion while Marcus
is appointed as director of the newly
founded umbrella training facility
Spencer's plan is to create a race of
superhumans dubbed project Wesker and
this nefarious plan sees umbrella kidnap
a whole load of children to be loyal
foot soldiers to Spencer's cause and
they are all brainwashed and injected
with the progenitor virus sadly most of
them die except for a certain Albert
Wesker who will come to be quite
familiar with across this timeline
meanwhile in Antarctica Alexander
ashford's Code Veronica project is
finally complete in 1971 Ashford creates
two clones from his family a Alfred and
Alexia fast forward to January 1978 yep
the 70s were seemingly sparse for the
resi franchise and Marcus is making a
breakthrough with his research at the
umbrella Training Facility by splicing
the progenitor with leech DNA he creates
the T virus or at least a strain that
doesn't immediately kill those exposed
to it it just turns them into hideously
mutated creatures not sure which one of
those is the better option if I'm honest
his research is assisted by two students
from the umbrella training facility
doctors William Birkin and Albert Wesker
but their work together does not last
long as at the end of the school year
the umbrella training facility is closed
down and Burke in Wesker and the t-virus
are all moved to Spencer's art play
research Labs suspicious of Spencer's
motives Marcus continues to stay behind
with his work and experiments on
anything and everything from mammals to
reptiles all of which will pop up as end
of level bosses in Resident Evil Zero
the early 1980s are not a good time for
the Ashford family remember Alexia well
she's grown up to become a 10 year old
child Mastermind and is promptly
appointed the senior researcher at
umbrella's Antarctica lab much the
anoint of 21 year old wesca keep up
Albert after learning about their origin
as clones Alexia and her brother Alfred
vowed to hunt down and capture their
father which they succeed in doing in
1983 with Alexander in custody Alexi
uses him as a test subject for Research
into her new version of the T Virus
known as the T Veronica virus
surprise surprise the experiment turned
him into a psychotic monster later known
as Nosferatu no not that one taking the
failed experiment on the chin Alexia
uses the data she obtained on her father
to inject herself with the tea Veronica
virus while she peacefully sweeped the
effects off in a cryogenic chamber for
15 years don't worry we'll come back to
this mad child prodigy later on back in
the arclay labs research on the virus
now headed up by William Birkin has
stalled umbrella have discovered that 10
of the population are naturally immune
to the virus and Birkin sets himself The
Morbid task of solving this unique
problem his answer comes in the form of
a bio-organic weapon or bow for sure
known as the hunter which is born
through splicing reptilian and human DNA
with the t-virus birkin's research and
development continues across the 80s and
culminates with the start of a little
project known as the tyrant
okay it's late 1988 and I think it's
about time we catch up with our good pal
James Marcus who's slowly been going off
the rails with his own brand of the
t-virus research as an independent
researcher Marcus makes Headway by
continuing to experiment with leeches
and in some extreme cases his own staff
and he eventually creates his magnum
opus the queen leech his old mate Oswell
Spencer is having none of this though
and seeks to regain control of the
t-virus research by assassinating Marcus
and stealing his work he sends in a team
of umbrella soldiers alongside wesca and
Birkin and they shoot and kill Marcus
before dumping his body and his precious
Queen leech at a nearby sewerage
treatment I wonder if they'll crop back
up in this story spoilers they do
[Music]
thank you
the 90 sees umbrella expand their
operations across the arclay mountains
and into neighboring Raccoon City with
Birkin making significant progress with
his research creating the superior G
virus in the process Spencer commissions
a gigantic underground lab to be built
underneath the city a job that he covers
up by bribing Raccoon City police chief
Brian irons Brian's fast forward to 1996
and the raccoon
fast forward to 1996 and the Raccoon
City Police Department instigate the
inaugural special
fast forward to 1996 and the Raccoon
City Police Department instigate the
inaugural special tactics and Rescue
Services Unit All Stars for short
you are a pesky animal although it's
under the jurisdiction of the RPD it
remains a privately funded independent
Venture namely so umbrella can keep
their fingers in the pie disgusting
during this time Albert Wesker is
assigned to Stars by umbrella and he
quickly becomes the captain of the
squad's Alpha Team right we have finally
reached the most pivotal year in the
entire Resident Evil timeline
1998 a year in which a whopping five
games in the franchise take place in May
1998 there is a catastrophic outbreak of
the t-virus at the Spencer Mansion labs
and a handful of Cerberus zombie dogs to
you and me escape into the arclay
mountains and start killing unfortunate
hikers in an attempt to contain the
outbreak umbrella locks down the Mansion
lab and the t-virus begins to spread
among the poor staff still there
naturally with the horrific nature of
the arclay killings the stories emerging
inspire a media Firestorm and the press
start putting pressure on the RPD to to
get the situation under control Chief
irons dispatches the Stars Alpha and
Bravo teams to investigate the
surrounding mountains with weska
overseeing the missions unbeknownst to
the rest of his teams though wesk is
directed from umbrella HQ is instead to
gain critical information about the
site's bows and destroy the Mansion
before it is discovered alongside that
he is ordered to gather information
about the Bow's combat ability
specifically in their interactions with
the incoming Stars teams
[Music]
and so we finally reached the very first
game in the Resident Evil timeline which
details the Stars Bravo team's failed
Mission the Bravo Team make their way
out to the arclay mountains only for
their helicopter to crash on Route
courtesy of a little bit of sabotage
from our good mate weska instead of
making for the Spencer Mansion as per
their original plan the team stumbled
onto the wreck of a military Convoy with
all the soldiers very much dead they
discovered that the troop had been
escorting accused murderer Billy Cohen
and putting two and two together and
making five assume Billy is the lad
responsible for all the brutal killings
they split up and rookie Stars member
Rebecca Chambers quickly discovers an
abandoned train the ecliptic Express now
remember that I said that James Marcus
and his Queen leech would make her come
back into this story well boy what a
comeback it is it turns out that when
umbrella dumped Marcus and his leech in
that sewerage facility the leech slowly
ate away at Marcus's body and mind
effectively absorbing his personality
the end result was a reincarnated Marcus
leech hybrid thing hell-bent on Revenge
with umbrella this franchise is totally
Bonkers but I absolutely love it with
Marcus back from the dead he goes to
town on the poor inhabitants of the
train and by the time Rebecca Chambers
stumbles onto the train they are all
dead well Undead I guess having been
consumed by Marcus's Army of leeches
Rebecca boards the train encounters
death row inmate Billy Cohen and they
start to investigate the express Keen to
get the train back on its journey wesca
and Birkin send in a team of umbrella
soldiers who succeed in getting the
train underway but promptly get chomped
by the leeches Rebecca and Billy managed
to bring the train to a stop or be a
messy one and emerge from the wreckage
at the umbrella training facility Marcus
or the hybrid leech thing reveals
himself to Westgate and Birkin and this
leads the duo to activate the facility's
self-destruct function caught in the
middle of all of this are poor Rebecca
and Billy who navigate their way out of
the facility killed the queen leech and
get to safety before the place blows Sky
High
as they Overlook the destruction Rebecca
allows the actually innocent Billy to go
free and she leaves him to go and help
Alpha Team at a familiar looking Mansion
the game then ends with Billy giving the
cheesiest thumbs up I've ever seen
[Music]
okay we are now with the OG Resident
Evil which details the exploits of Alpha
Team in their mission to investigate the
arclay killings headed up by Wesker the
Stars Squad includes expert Marksman
Chris Redfield Jill Valentine the master
of unlocking top explosives lad Barry
Burton and helicopter pilot Brad Vickers
the team successfully land near the
Mansion but I quickly caught off guard
by a pack of zombie dogs which forces
them into the Spencer Mansion separated
they each make their way through the
illogical Maze of corridors encountering
and surviving the zombified umbrella
staff bows and various other mutations
meanwhile wesca is pulling the strings
behind the scenes he strong arms barrier
into helping him set traps for the rest
of the Stars team by threatening to kill
his family Chris and Jill survive
everything and anything that's thrown at
them sharks snakes spiders bad dialogue
and they meet up with Rebecca Chambers
on their way to getting out of them
Mansion wesca is finally revealed to be
a traitor to Alpha Team and as a result
he releases umbrella's Tyrant project a
huge mutated man mountain in a bid to
kill the remaining Stars members Chris
Jill and Rebecca fight off the Tyrant
and thanks to the impeccable timing of
Vicar's return with the helicopter they
all Escape as the Spencer Mansion
self-distracts there's definitely a
pattern emerging here right amidst a
chaos weska manages to survive as well
albeit without the critical bow samples
he intended together and he leaves
umbrella for good
okay a couple of months have passed and
we catch up with Jill Valentine during
the events of Resident Evil 3 Nemesis
under pressure from umbrella Stars has
been disbanded and nobody believes the
team about what they saw in the arclay
mountains the t-virus has very much
arrived in downtown Raccoon City having
spread from that gigantic underground
lab that somehow remained secret with
the zombie population on the rise there
is chaos in the streets and the RPD is
quickly overwhelmed
umbrella in a series of questionable
decisions starts deploying bows all
across Raccoon City
Chief among them is the Dapper Mr X and
the titular foe of resi III nemesis
Nemesis is given the mission of hunting
down former Stars members and keeping
this momentum going he begins his
unrelenting Chase of Jill Valentine
across town the umbrella biohazard
countermeasure service God that's a
mouthful arrive and start evacuating
anyone who's not a zombie in her
attempts to escape Jill runs into ubcs
team member Carlos Oliveira and the pair
take the fight to Nemesis while trying
to escape the ruins of the city during
their fight Jill becomes infected with
the t-virus leaving poor Carlos to fend
for himself and find a cure for Jill
will she survive we'll have to wait
until later because we've got a date
with a blonde hunk
foreign
concurrently with Resident Evil 3 is the
campaign to Resident Evil 2 which sees
new cop on the Block Leon Kennedy and
Chris redfield's sister Claire appear
for the first time in the franchise Leon
arrives in Raccoon City for his first
day on the job in the middle of the
zombie apocalypse after encountering
Claire Redfield who's searching for her
brother Chris at an out of town gas
station the pair make their way into the
Heart of the City before getting
separated during a car accident Leon
eventually makes his way to the RPD
which is completely overrun with zombies
after navigating the station's bizarre
lock and key setup it is an old Museum
after all Leon finds himself down in the
cells where he runs into the mysterious
Ada Wong Ada's mission is to swipe a
vial of the g-virus and Leon agrees to
go along with it the naive heartthrob as
they're investigating the pair are
attacked by Mr X and they escape into
the sewers where they encounter Annette
Birkin wife of umbrella scientist
William Annette inches Ada and informs
Leon that he's working with a mercenary
who wants to sell the virus on the black
market Leon the fool that he is descends
into birkin's lab anyway swipes the
g-virus and returns to Ada who
immediately holds him up at gunpoint for
it Annette pops up one last time shoots
Ada and in the ensuing chaos the g-virus
and Ada fall into the abyss as Leon
tries to escape the lab Mr X makes one
last Encore before being dispatched by a
handy rocket launcher that is thrown to
him by Ada who has miraculously survived
her fall meanwhile Claire encounters a
young girl Sherry daughter of William
Birkin and they managed to escape a
giant creature by taking refuge in the
RPD car park where they meet morally
bankrupt police chief Brian irons
Brian's Brian kidnaps Sherry and locks
her in a neighboring abandoned orphanage
as Claire mounts a rescue mission a
tyrant drops in on irons infecting him
with a parasite irons dyes and Sherry
flees while Claire manages to escape
into the sewers only to bump into
Sherry's mum Annette who reveals that
the creature chasing her daughter is in
fact her mutated father turns out our
will had plans to sell his geovirus
creation to the US military a plan that
didn't go down too well with umbrella
who promptly sent in a team to kill him
to save himself Birkin injected himself
with the g-virus turning the good doctor
into a repulsive monster in the ensuing
Carnage he destroyed a bunch of t-virus
stores which led to the Raccoon City
outbreak when Claire and Annette find
Sherry they discover that she's already
been infected by her father and the pair
hatch a plan to find a cure from within
birkin's labs Claire succeeds in finding
an antidote and in the chaos of getting
back to kyosheri a net is killed by her
husband naturally the whole facility
enacts the now contractually obliged
self-destruct function and Claire and
Sherry escape to an evacuation train
where they meet back up with Leon Birkin
has one more crack at killing them fails
and is then caught in the fires of the
exploding labs
[Music]
wrap up that Cliffhanger from earlier
Carlos being the absolute lad that he is
scavenges a cure for Jill because by
this stage they're just lying around the
waist of raccoon city and she recovers
from her infection the pair make their
way through a series of underground
umbrella labs in an attempt to escape
the city before it's nuked from the air
it's the only way to be sure on Route
they're ambushed by good old Nemesis one
last time and Jill fires the killing
blow with the biggest of big guns
after defeating Nemesis and overpowering
one of Carlos's corrupt Squad mates the
pair ride off into the sunset and
raccoon city is reduced to ashes behind
them
[Music]
all right three months have passed since
the devastation in Raccoon City and
Claire Redfield is still searching for
her brother Chris her search takes her
to an umbrella facility in Paris where
she is eventually caught in a sequence
heavily riffing on John Woo
umbrella locked her up in an isolated
prison in the Southern Ocean known as
Rockford Island and lo and behold there
is an outbreak of the t-virus on the
island and Claire soon gets set free
soon after she encounters the world's
most irritating Canadian a floppy-haired
lad called Steve Burnside and the pair
team up to escape the island
in their way stands Alfred Ashford one
of the Clones created by Umbrella
co-founder Alexander Ashford and well
he's gone a bit insane his time alone
and apart from his twin sister Alexia
has led him to cultivate a split
personality and he switches frequently
between the identities of himself and
Alexia Claire and Steve soon break free
from Rockford Island only for Alfred to
divert their plane to the nearby
umbrella facility in Antarctica using
the systems autopilot override Crash
Landing in Antarctica the pair finally
defeat Alfred who uses his final spark
of life to awaken his sister Alexia from
her cryosleep she's not the only Ashford
in Antarctica though turns out Papa
Alexander Ashford the other Nosferatu is
still around and he's hungry for Revenge
as Claire squares off against the
Hideous remains of Alexander Alexia
takes control of the situation and
catches our heroic Duo as they attempt
to escape meanwhile back on Rockville
Island Chris has turned up searching for
his sister in his search of the island
he bumps into none other than Dr Albert
Wesker who has gone Rogue from umbrella
since the Spencer Mansion incident and
is there to retrieve a sample of the tea
Veronica virus with their goals both in
Antarctica the pair separately make
haste for the umbrella base once there
Chris saves Claire poor Steve becomes
infected and dies Alexia is finally
defeated and that sneaky bastard Wesker
makes off with Steve's tea Veronica
virus riddled body all while umbrella's
Antarctica base yup you guessed it
self-destructs
thank you
next up on our timeline is the we like
gun spin-off Resident Evil Darkseid
Chronicles which largely regales the
events of Resident Evil 2 and Code
Veronica but it does have one story
mission that is unique and takes our
timeline a little bit further and that's
Operation Javier
four years after the disastrous events
in Raccoon City Leon Kennedy and special
ops member Jack krauser are dispatched
to South America to apprehend cartel
leader Javier Hidalgo who has apparently
infected his daughter Manuela with the
Veronica virus Leon and krauser
encounter and secure Manuela before
proceeding to hidalgo's complex there
they defeat Javier who has fused himself
with the Veronica virus to become some
kind of giant killer plant and they
escape with Manuela via helicopter
during the fight Krauser's arm is
wounded and becomes infected and as a
result he's discharged from the US Army
this leads him down a darker path as he
contacts rezzy big bad Albert Wesker to
join his team
[Music]
Umbrella Chronicles is next on our
timeline and it largely re-treads
grounds from Resident Evil 0 1 and 3.
but he does have a unique Story Mission
called umbrella's end and I'm guessing
you can figure out what that entails the
year is 2003. Chris Redfield and Jill
Valentine are investigating umbrella's
last known stronghold a facility in
Russia which is developing a new bio
weapon known as the Talos project Chris
and Jill being the experts that they are
infiltrate the facility and destroy the
Talos but wait who's that on the horizon
it's only bloody Wesker again here to
take his final revenge on umbrella weska
flings his coat into the camera like an
absolute Nutter it must be freezing out
there and he tears his way into the
compound he encounters Sergey Vladimir a
high-ranking umbrella leader who has
been working closely with Lord Spencer
to keep umbrella going in the wake of
the Raccoon City outbreaks Sergey is no
match for Wesker though who quickly
dispatches him and steals umbrella's
deepest darkest Secrets which he then
makes public as a result umbrella loses
its long-standing legal battle with the
US government a dispute that's been
going on since 1998 and umbrella
declares bankruptcy as a result nothing
more exciting than Court proceedings to
bring an evil monster creating
incorporation to its knees a lads
with
[Music]
umbrella a thing of the past Resident
Evil 4 kicks off a new era for the
franchise Rizzi IV is a largely
self-contained chapter in the franchise
taking the series away from its
zombified roots the year is 2004 and
Leon Kennedy is dispatched to rescue the
American president's daughter Ashley
from a mysterious cult and deepest
darkest Spain he arrives at a creepy
rural Farmstead populated by a group of
hostile villagers who have pledged their
allegiance to the cult of Los
illuminaros The Villages are effectively
being controlled by a parasite known as
Las plagas with the cult leader Osmond
Sadler calling the shots Leon after
surviving chainsaws Giants and a mutated
salamander finally tracks down Ashley to
a nearby church and the pair later
escaped to a castle which doesn't look
menacing in the slightest jokes it's
under the control of creepy man-child
Ramon Salazar another of Sadler's
henchmen when Leon and actually get
separated amidst the Castle's deadly
traps Leon encounters an old
acquaintance the lady in the red dress
Ada Wong long time no see the lady Leon
battles his way out of the castle
killing a mutated Salazar and makes his
way to find Ashley at an offshore island
facility old acquaintances are like
London buses it seems as Leon then bumps
into his former special ops buddy Jack
krauser krauser then reveals that he and
Ada are both working for Wesker to
secure the last Plagueis parasite and
Leon being The Good Egg boy that he is
defeats him Leon then confronts Sadler
himself killing him Atop The Island's
research facility with a good
old-fashioned rocket launcher to the
face courtesy again of ADA Ada then
holds Leon up at gunpoint again and she
makes off with a sample of the last
Plagueis virus meanwhile Leon and Ashley
escaped the island self-destruct
sequence on jet skis
Resident Evil 4 what game
[Music]
Resident Evil Revelations takes place
smack bang between rezzies 4 and 5 and
introduces the bioterrorism security
assessment Alliance into the mix or bsaa
for fans of acronyms in the wake of a
bioterrorism attack that destroys the
city of Terror grigia bsaa agents Jill
Valentine and Parker Luciani are
dispatched to the last known location of
their missing team members Chris
Redfield who's now got massive arms and
Jessica sherawat the last known location
turns out to be the queen Zenobia
Cruiser which is drifting in the
Mediterranean Sea seemingly abandoned
while there Jill and Parker are ambushed
by an organization called veltro the
folks responsible for the previous buyer
attacks and they are imprisoned the bsaa
makes contact with Chris why didn't they
do that in the first place and sends him
and Jessica in to rescue Jill and Parker
and they make for the Zenobia Chris and
Jill eventually reunite because that's
what everyone really wants and foil a
plot to contaminate the sea with a virus
known as the T Abyss at some point
they're just going to run out of names
for these viruses
oh
right time for something a little
different and by different I mean mostly
the same but now it's a film the first
of a Trilogy of CG animated movies
Resident Evil degeneration C Series Star
Wars Leon S Kennedy and Claire Redfield
foil another raccoon city-like
bioterrorism plot but this time it's on
a wider scale across the whole us it
kind of feels like you're watching a 90
minute long and unskippable cutscene
when all you want to do is explore a bit
and shoot some zombies in the face
a year or so later we get the Mad
conspiracy Shenanigans of the Netflix
series Resident Evil infinite Darkness
after a civil war in the fictional
nation of pen amstan a war in which the
U.S sent in a special operations unit
known as The Mad Dogs Leon and Claire
come back together to untangle a
potential cover-up alluding to the use
of bioweapons long story short there is
a cover-up within the White House no
less which Claire manages to well
uncover while the blonde curtains
himself gallivants on a globetrotting
adventure to China and back to stop a
tyrant-esque super soldier which he
naturally does because he's Leon S
Kennedy and the S stands for stop using
bioweapons
[Music]
fast forward
and our Dream Team Chris and Jill have
finally Tracked Down the last remaining
co-founding member of umbrella Lord
Oswell e Spencer Jill the master of
unlocking uses a lock pick to break into
Spencer's residence and the duo make
their way through the Mansion until they
encounter not Spencer but Wesker having
arrived ahead of them wesca brutally
murders Spencer by just punching him
right through the chest it's just
devastating weska then squares off
against Chris and Jill and as the battle
comes to its conclusion Jill rugby
tackles wesca out of a window and they
both plummet down a cliff did they
survive of course they did weska
cryogenically freezes Jill in
preparation four
[Music]
foreign
yeah we're heading to Africa for
Resident Evil 5 which takes place nearly
three years later the game follows Chris
Redfield and bsaa partner Sheva Alamar
as they investigate an outbreak on the
last Plagueis parasite in an African
Town Chris and Sheva stop an illegal
arms deal and as a result stumble onto
evidence that Jill is still alive driven
to find his old partner Chris continues
the investigation and the pair find
themselves in the cave that started this
whole mad franchise off in the first
place yeah they ReDiscover the origins
of the t-virus this Stairway To The
Sunflower and uncover a conspiracy
involving the bsaa's parent company
trisel who have been sneakily continuing
on with umbrella's research Chris and
Shiva eventually catch up to jail
Valentine sporting a new blonde haircut
and wrestle her in order to remove a
mind-control device that is attached to
her chest to absolutely no one's
surprise Wesker reveals himself with
another well-destroying clan this time
it's firing missile files containing a
virus known as uraboris all around the
world our Trio chase wesca down and
eventually Corner him in an active
volcano because by this point why the
[__] not Chris and Sheva take the fight
to Wesker and in Chris's case some poor
innocent defenseless Boulders that
probably had friends and family that
cared for them and they eventually kill
Wesker once and for all by firing yep
you guessed it ladies and gentlemen it's
the crowd favorite resi's big bad killer
an RPG right into his smug face
next up on this timeline is Resident
Evil Revelations 2 a game whose story
was heavily inspired by Czech author
Franz Kafka a fact that I literally just
found out while writing this timeline to
make my job even more complicated
Revelations 2 takes place across two
different timelines the first sees
Claire Redfield and Moira Burton
daughter of Ginger Legend Barry being
kidnapped and imprisoned on shush
foreign
stop knee an Island by a mysterious
woman known as the Overseer in a weird
kafka-esque experiment of sorts the
prisoners are fitted with bracelets that
track Their Fear levels get too afraid
and you turn into a monster ooh
symbolism the second timeline however
sees Barry arrive on the island in an
attempt to rescue his daughter a
whopping six months later the story then
unfolds over four episodes each of them
named after a Kafka short story and
follows Claire and moira's attempts to
escape and Barry's Rescue Mission Barry
encounters a little girl known as
Natalya who reveals that the overseer is
in fact Alex Wesker contrary to popular
belief not assisted to Albert Wesker but
another child that has survived
umbrella's heinous project Wesker two
whiskers
the quartet finally managed to escape
the island if you got the good ending
that is and defeat Alex with oh boy is
that yeah it is it's back the most
classic of Resident Evil madman
murdering weapons the rocket launcher
before we get into The Madness of
Resident Evil 6 we've got another jaunt
back into the CG film Trilogy with the
middle entry Resident Evil damnation
damnation is a considerable improvement
over its predecessor and sees Leon S
Kennedy catapulted back into the story
this time around Leon Ventures to
Eastern Europe to investigate rumors
that bows are being used in a local
Civil War obviously they are and he
spends the run time trying to clean up
the mess with occasional help and
hindrance from the lady in red herself
Ada Wong
[Music]
oh my God where do I even start with
Resident Evil 6.
foreign
like a greatest hits of the franchise
Resident Evil 6 features a bloated
monster of a storyline with not one not
two not even bloody three but four
different campaigns and seven major
characters the story kicks off on
Christmas Eve 2012 with Jake Mueller the
son of the late Albert weska hang on
when did he get busy yeah weska [__]
being taken into custody by a grown-up
Sherry Birkin who is now a bsaa agent
Muller is the key to creating a vaccine
to the new sea virus but birkin's
mission to extract him from the
fictional country of Adonia is put on
hold when they are hunted down by a new
bio weapon called ustenack which is like
Nemesis on steroids to add insult to
injury during the attack they are
abducted by an imposter calling herself
Ada Wong meanwhile bsaa agents Chris
Redfield and Pierce nivans are in the
same neighborhood to keep the local
infected population under control they
soon come under attack from a new
organization calling itself Neo umbrella
supposedly led by Ada Wong and their
whole Squad is wiped out by the Sea
virus fast forward six months and the
American president is about to air
umbrella's dirty laundry from the 1998
Raccoon City outbreaks but there's
another bioterrorism attack and the
president is infected forcing our old
friend Leon Kennedy to kill him Leon
uncovers that the National Security
adviser Derek Simmons was behind the
attack and he tracks down Simmons to a
Neo umbrella lab in langshayang China
with his partner Helena Harper Chris and
piers are then dispatched to Lang
shayang to hunt down Ada and they come
into contact with Leon and Helena who
informed them that the aided that they
are hunting is in fact a clone following
their running with Chris Leon and Helena
finally confront and defeat a mutated
Simmons Leon then dispatches Chris and
Piers to an oil rig to rescue Jake and
Sherry and prevent another large-scale
bioterrorism attack this time courtesy
of a bio weapon called chaos this
kitchen approach to storytelling all
dovetails into a messy conclusion that
sees Pierce inject himself with the sea
virus to defeat chaos Sherry and Jake
then killed the Behemoth Houston Act and
the real Ada destroys the lab where her
clone was created
that was a lot and I didn't even mention
the fact that the logo looks like a
giraffe being sucked off by a
unfortunately the film Trilogy closer
Resident Evil Vendetta also throws
everything in the kitchen sink into its
overstuffed narrative too Vendetta
brings Chris and Leon back together
again but also throws Rebecca Chambers
back into the mix yeah remember her last
time we saw her on the timeline was all
the way back in the original rezzy like
20 or so minutes ago anyway this Trio of
bioterrorism busting badasses get
embroiled in yet another attempt to
unleash a new virus on the unsuspecting
citizens of the world but this time it's
a virus with a new name the a virus
because well that letter wasn't yet
taken long story short the trio succeed
and along the way there's fan favorites
all over the shop a new Tyrant a
launcher of the grenade variety and of
course lots and lots of virus riddled
zombies
[Music]
right after the Bonkers pass of the last
couple of entries it's time to take
things back to basics with the swampland
horror of Resident Evil 7. the year is
2014 and all hell is about to break
loose for the baker family after
encountering an abandoned tanker in the
Louisiana bio Jack Baker finds a little
girl and brings her back to the family
home all appears normal until the girl
wakes up and causes the Bakers to go
well
fast forward three years to the summer
of 2017 for the main plot of Resident
Evil 7 which sees poor Ethan Winters
encounter the Charming Baker family
while he searches for his missing wife
Mia
as Ethan endures the delightful
Hospitality of the Bakers welcome to the
family song
he soon discovers that his wife and the
family have been infected with a
mold-like fungus that turns them super
aggressive he escapes the hellish
residence with help from the baker's
daughter Zoe defeating Jack and
Margarita along the way Ethan eventually
discovers that his wife Mia was working
as an operative for an organization that
developed the little girl known as
Evelyn into a bioweapon Evelyn escapes
and well you know the rest of the story
Ethan finally encounters Evelyn face to
Giant face eventually killing her before
being rescued by none other than Boulder
murderer Chris Redfield the pair
escaping a helicopter with Mia if you
chose to cure her and they fly off into
the sunrise wait is that an umbrella
logo on the side of that helicopter well
sort of in the wake of umbrella's messy
end another company known as Blue
Umbrella emerged From the Ashes with the
primary goal to clean up the mess of the
original Corporation
in the wake of the baker residence
outbreak Chris Redfield assists blue
umbrella in capturing Lucas the last
remaining Baker before he reveals the
secrets of Evelyn's infection to
nefarious nerdy Wells game over
[Music]
and so we reached the final destination
of this madcap roller coaster of a
franchise Resident Evil Village or
Resident Evil 8 age if you're being
pedantic three and a half years have
passed since the Carnage of Rezi 7 and
Ethan Amir Winters are living a
relatively normal life with their
newborn daughter rose that is until our
pal Chris Redfield and his Hound wolf
Squad storm the Winter's resonance and
kidnap hapless Ethan and baby Rose Ethan
and his daughter are taken out of town
but before they can reach their
destination their truck is ambushed the
little Nipper Rose is kidnapped by
someone else and Ethan is Left for Dead
gosh this lad just can't catch a break
any he awakens to this new Nightmare and
Ventures into a nearby Village to search
for Rose The Village in question is like
something out of a universal monster
movie complete with actual werewolves
roaming the street and a Dracula alike
Countess lording over a giant spooky
Castle after the former nearly
eviscerates poor Ethan he's imprisoned
by the latter a giant lady vampire known
as lady dimitrisk having been tipped off
by a mysterious Merchant known simply as
the Duke Ethan discovers that Rosemary
has been killed oh God and her body
parts scattered across the village in
four different flasks damn that's dark
the four different flasks have been
entrusted to four different Lords or in
a massive callback to the very beginning
of this video four of mother Miranda's
kadu parasite experiments one by one
Ethan systematically dispatches these
monstrosities starting with the
aforementioned tall vampire lady
dimitrisk before offing puppet possessor
Donna benevento giant Fishman Salvatore
Moreau and finally Magneto on steroids
Carl Heisenberg after dispatching
Heisenberg Ethan discovers that Chris is
in the neighborhood and he tracks him
down to have a good in for shooting his
wife Chris explains that the mayor he
shot was actually mother Miranda in
Disguise and that she's pulling the
strings on this whole damn puppet show
this surreal nightmare comes to her head
when Ethan confronts Miranda only to die
for his troubles don't worry we haven't
seen the back or face either to be
honest of this lad just yet having
witnessed Ethan's death Chris assembles
his Wolfhound Squad and they Venture
deep under the village where they
discover the truth behind mother Miranda
and her experiments with the mega my
seat Chris has planned to deal with this
truth blow the [__] out of it he plants
a charge and vacates the premises cut to
Ethan who isn't dead well actually he is
but let me explain you see Ethan has
been dead since pretty much the very
beginning of Rezi 7. after his encounter
with Jack Baker the reason that he's
still alive is because he was infected
by the very mole that he was trying to
destroy in that game and its powers of
Revival have been keeping him breathing
ever since her that's why he can just
put his hand back on when it's chopped
off earlier in the game the revived
Ethan once again takes the fight to
Miranda who's halfway through trying to
revive her daughter Eva with Ethan's
timely intervention she actually revives
baby Rose and with his mission complete
Ethan kills Miranda and stays behind to
make sure Chris's bomb destroys the mega
my seat and as the mega my seat blows
Sky High Chris Jets off into the Horizon
with rose and a rescued Mia too having
found her held prisoner in the dungeons
of the castle
[Music]
before we close out this timeline
there's one last little epilogue that
wraps up the Winter Story with a nice
neat little bow and that's the story DLC
expansion Shadows of Rose it's 16 years
since the events of village and baby
Rose is all grown up and has sadly lived
a life of being bullied for her unique
powers a result of her time with Miranda
and the mega Micey wishing to be rid of
her powers she's given an opportunity to
shed them by her friend a lad simply
named K his proposition is for Rose to
enter the consciousness of A Shard of
the mega mice and recover a purifying
Crystal to help remove her abilities
instead of running for the hills at that
clearly mad idea Rose Dives on in and
finds herself in a warped version of the
Dimitris Castle trying to survive from a
dark version of The Merchant from the
main village campaign as she Dives
deeper through the various levels of the
mega mice Rose is aided by a disembodied
voice calling himself Michael his golden
words guide Rose Part the merchant a
horde of killer dolls and finally Evelyn
the big bad from Resident Evil 7. Rose
eventually nabs the purifying Crystal
but in the process comes face to face
with Mother Miranda who reveals that K
was an illusion and the whole setup was
a plot to use rose as a vessel to revive
her daughter either Michael also reveals
himself to be Ethan's Consciousness and
this lovely family reunion is promptly
ruined by Miranda baying for blood Ethan
and Rose eventually overpower Miranda
when Rose decides to keep her powers and
with Miranda dispatched once again Rose
finds herself back home in her own
reality and the game ends with rose at
her father's graveside being drafted
back into the machinations of some
shadowy organization and as they drive
off into the distance a mysterious
figure is seen approaching their car who
is he well I guess we'll have to wait
and see where this mad franchise goes
next for the answer to that and that
friends is the Resident Evil timeline in
a hideous he idiot nutshell I hope you
enjoyed this one if you did please make
sure to check out some of my other
timelines including Dead Space Metroid
and Uncharted thanks a lot for watching
guys I'll see you next time